would you televise the wedding
yeah it's not out of the question ish
are we
any closer i don't know why don't you
show them
oh wait what well congratulations on the
engagement
you guys said that if you popped the
question
on the day that you had your first full
day in your new home in la what day
exactly was that
may 1st you've had to keep this a secret
for a while now yes
how on earth did you keep this a secret
i mean were you not able to wear your
ring for
a bit of time i wore it out in la um
so i mean i i wanted to wear it all the
time
so and but like it was good because like
none of my castmates were there so like
i knew
and kelsey and chloe already knew so it
was just the rest of them we were really
trying to keep it a secret from so it
would be a surprise on the reunion
are you guys wedding planning right now
it's so hard just because like the state
of the world is just so
unknown right now so i like obviously
like i'm looking at
instagram inspiration and stuff and like
wedding dresses
um but i can't walk down a date or a
venue right now
yeah ish i love that you smiled when she
said that
well i mean it is tough because uh we
were actually supposed to go to greece
uh last month i think for one of her
friends weddings so
a lot of people unfortunately have had
to cancel or
you know postpone their wedding so it's
not a really good time
unfortunately i'm sure she has been
digging into
a few things here and there but it's
really hard to figure out
you know when borders are going to open
up where we're going to do it and like
there's a lot of
obviously a lot that goes into it but
you know
what what does the dream wedding look
like is it a massive
over-the-top ordeal is it intimate small
um i think somewhere in the middle i
want like a good amount of people there
but
i know that the only thing i know for
sure right now is i want
like a winter holiday wedding just
because i think it's like so magical
around christmas time
so i really want that
would you televise the wedding
yeah it's not out of the question i mean
i think i'm more
more inclined to do that than ish is but
we'll see
ish ish why would you be hesitant to do
that
my role is behind the camera but i
you know obviously i want to be a part
of it and you know
it's uh it's it's part of her life
for each of you guys three wedding
must-haves
that no matter what you just have to
have at your on the big day
well just having my family obviously is
huge and having my three sisters like
next to me is just
so cool to think about yeah um
other than that i mean i do want a
winter wedding like i said
um and
i don't i haven't even thought of it um
i think i i really want to do like the
traditional like i don't want ish to see
me before
like i want to stick like we don't spend
that night together i like that idea and
he doesn't know
what what the wedding dress looks like
so i love that
oh that's so cute no this is a big one
we have to write our vows
i want like i definitely want that is
for you
uh wow to put me on the spot i would
love well obviously i definitely want my
family there i'd like for
um my family to to be in attendance
obviously
and really a lot of it i mean i just
want her to be happy it's i mean
as i don't want to say like put it off
on like oh it's her dates or whatever
but
it really is a special day for her so i
want to make sure that
everything she's ever dreamt of in terms
of her wedding
she has so it's really it's really
whatever she wants and i'll be there to
support her and we'll make it happen
madison you mentioned your sisters you
want them next to you will you have
anyone from siesta key
also next to you bridesmaids are you
even thinking that far ahead
i haven't thought about like what
specific bridesmaids
want so far but i mean i'll definitely
ask kelsey
okay and and chloe no yeah maybe i
have to figure out how many i i'm going
to have first like how many he's going
to have because i want
to like match up yeah but yeah
that's okay that's definitely a thought
i feel like a lot of your guys's friends
question this relationship and madison
your parents
your dad obviously seems pretty serious
but at this point i'm not convinced that
this is in my
daughter's best interest how did your
parents really feel about
the engagement i mean my mom was stoked
she's always been
very supportive of our relationship from
day one but
i mean if you can speak to how my dad
felt he called him and like asked for
his blessing and everything
i was gonna ask that her dad was great
he
um obviously it took him a little while
and it's
you know i can't blame him we've had
we've talked about it like i'm sure he
would feel this way about all of his
daughters but madison's his youngest so
i get it he's very protective and every
father should be so
um i totally understood where he was
coming from
um and i get it i ideally you know if
like i was a father i would probably
have the same sort of reservations
um but i did call him he obviously gave
us our blessing he's been
an amazing you know he's been great he's
been
super super cool super super open very
kind
and like madison said her mother has
always been on board her sisters all
came around i called each and every one
of them
um before i asked so i had to get
permission from
not just the father but you know her
sisters and her mother um
so i wanted to make sure that they were
all on board before i go
what did uh her dad say to you when you
first called and asked for permission
was
was it like a long extensive thing well
i tried to get a hold of him
uh and we were texting back and forth
and i and i said i really need to talk
to you
um and he kind of put me on ice for a
day he knew it was coming so he did it
it was coming and he's like we'll talk
later yeah so i was chomping at the bit
the next day
because i wanted to do it um you know
when we got the keys and we had our
first day there
but he finally hit me back and we had a
nice conversation and you know he
obviously gave me his blessing so
yeah it was a really special moment for
for me you know knowing that
we've come so far and you know we're now
at this point where he's
he's open to it and he's embraced me and
and you know has welcomed me to the
family
i think that was more of like the
exciting part than like getting a yes
from me because he knew that was gonna
happen so i was like getting a yes from
my dad
sure yeah were you emotional at all like
did you cry or anything
either of you i did and
ish did you um did i cry i don't think i
could yes you did
i like him he's like i don't think i did
mean they're happy tears that's a good
thing
how is it living together in l.a
um i mean we've only lived together
during quarantine so it was really good
because we got to spend like so much
time together and it was like
just us and we just got to like really
get to know ourselves like that way
yeah but then obviously he left for
canada
um so it's been tough but
it's okay i want to start a family are
you
you're ready for that like you're ready
to have a kid
like yes i want to act i do want to act
and i know that's what i want to do now
but like
i want to be a mother madison you were
very vocal
on the show about wanting to be a mom
yes
what does this engagement mean in terms
of that timeline is that an
active conversation that you guys are
still having do you think it'll be baby
before wedding
i mean i think now that we're engaged i
think it's wedding before baby
okay um because i can like just focus on
that and i don't need to rush it
um but yeah i mean it's definitely still
a conversation and something that is
going to happen
for sure ish how do you feel about
becoming a dad one day
um i'm excited i mean it's actually um
when she says it's a conversation that
we have it's a daily conversation
but it's great now i'm looking forward
to it um you know i
think madison's gonna be an amazing
mother and i you know i couldn't have
asked for
a better partner hmm i love that
speaking of babies there was another big
bombshell that came out of the reunion
oh my god i mean brandon's a dad
that whole situation seemed pretty it
gives me goosebumps it's so
cool 10 months ago i hooked up with this
girl
and she told me recently that
i have a kid with her
i mean when when did you guys find all
of that
out i had found out
um just a couple days before the reunion
yeah i think um it was some
like a lot of people on i think it was
just me
juliet chloe and kelsey that knew i
don't think amanda knew
it was a big like bomb for all of us
have you talked to him or camilla
i've talked to camilla a little bit i
want to like obviously i'm there friend
wants support and wants to
reach out um but i think he kind of
is figuring it out right now and i don't
want to like
step on any toes um so
i i don't know what his status is with
although he posted a picture with a baby
so he has like met the baby now and
and quincy's beautiful it's really cute
how is camilla doing
i mean that's like a big pill to swallow
yeah i mean i don't want to speak for
her but i texted her last night and just
like
checked in with her after watching the
reunion and she said it was hard to
re-watch
but i would also venture to guess that
they are not
speaking or um back together at all yeah
i was going to ask you if you ever see
them getting back together
i mean because brandon said a couple of
times how much he loves camilla during
that reunion
i have no idea i don't know if they can
work it out i mean
wonderful but also like that's
her choice another big piece of news
that came out a few months ago was that
alex was being
pretty much cut out of the show yeah how
did you feel like the show came out
without him and do you still stand by
that decision 100
i do stand by the decision um i also the
posts were from 2013.
i don't think any of us believe that he
still
believes those things or we wouldn't
have hung around him for so long
um juliette wouldn't have dated him if
she thought he was like an actively
racist human being but i do think
it's very important for um it was
important for mtv to make that decision
and stand
by the black community um but yeah i
obviously don't believe he still feels
that way and
i hope he continues to grow and reflect
on those things as we all should
do you see yourself doing a fourth
season of siesta key i know that we
don't have any official news yet
but i mean obviously i would love to do
another season and i'm going to be
in siesta key planning my wedding with
my parents and
my friends and my family so yeah